[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono sempre stato un bambino che si
stufava delle cose normali e dei giochi
normali
avevo sempre bisogno di dare vita a
tutti quelli che potevano essere i miei
giochi in scatola per crearne di nuovi
quello che vedete nell'immagine mie cose
e mio nonno
il primo game designer della mia vita la
persona che sapeva raccontarmi la
mitologia greca davanti a un qualsiasi
il monte della costa siciliana
per me quel monte era la casa di
polifemo mio nonno è la persona che mi
ha insegnato a unire i puntini della
creatività collegandola a quella che è
stata la passione per la tecnologia
trasmessa da mio padre
il tutto per un incontro che sarà
definitivo nella mia vita che avverrà a
pochi mesi dalla foto l'incontro con i
videogiochi
il videogioco per me è un non è solo
stato un'occasione di divertimento ma è
stata un'occasione che mi ha permesso di
imparare anche tante cose mi ricordo in
quinta elementare
dovevo imparare le parole inglesi e le
città d'inghilterra e il videogioco mi
faceto in questa fase quali erano allora
i tre punti fondamentali quelle tre
regole che hanno permesso questo
apprendimento veloce e che valgono
ancora adesso nel videogioco
il primo è quello che si chiama
l'esperienza ottimale il flop e cioè
quella quell esperienza che coinvolge il
giocatore a 360 gradi
anima e corpo perché nel gioco bilanci
perfettamente la difficoltà e le
competenze e le abilità che il giocatore
a quando quindi questa competenza e
magari superiore l'esperienza risultato
più facile
ovviamente il giocatore si annoia quando
invece l'esperienza che vi propongo al
giocatore è troppo difficile allora nel
giocatore
subentra la frustrazione ma se questo
mix è perfetto allora sei nel flop e non
si parla solo di coinvolgimento che è
collegabile al divertimento è qualcosa
di oltre in questa sala c'è una persona
che l'anno scorso ha avuto un
bruttissimo incidente stradale dovendo
avere una degenza lunga gli ho prestato
una console portatile
alla fine di questa degenza mi
restituisce la console che mi dice marco
io giocando e videogiochi ho sentito
molto meno dolore o quasi non me ne
accorgevo per me era un antidolorifico
naturale non è solo il flow il corpo
principale del videogioco
questa immersione e favorita certamente
per quello che la cura che sia
nell'aspetto grafico nell'aspetto audio
e in quello che è l'esperienza che si
propone all'utente quindi come io
propongo ai menu come il videogioco
parla all'utente ma c'è ancora un
aspetto che è molto interessante è
quello del fallimento e cioè il
fallimento nel videogioco non è qualcosa
di negativo nella vita di un
videogiocatore
si dice che l'ottanta per cento delle
volte giocatore fallisca e il 20 per
cento invece finalmente riesce a vincere
grazie a dio il videogiocatore però non
è un masochista
ma è semplicemente quella persona
quell individuo che riesce a capire che
dal fallimento può trarre delle nozioni
per andare avanti nella propria
avventura e nelle avventure offerta dei
videogiochi c'è l'avventura
dell'apprendimento quei videogiochi che
da una parte devono divertire ma d'altra
parte hanno anche l'obiettivo di
insegnare qualcosa si chiamano clyde
game negli play the game
però questa ricetta qualche volta non
funziona e lo capiamo subito perché il
videogioco commerciale di fatto ha
un'audience di miglio
i giocatori mentre la play game che
magari deve insegnare qualcosa di molto
specifico giustamente ne ha di meno
mi sono allora ricordato a questo punto
di quello che mi è successo in quinta
elementare perché non far diventare i
videogiochi veri come io li chiamavo da
bambino a clive game bene in quali
ambiti noi possiamo riuscire a
utilizzare questi up live game speciali
quindi che derivano dai videogiochi
commerciali il primo ambito che possiamo
considerarle sono le risorse umane la
formazione il secondo ambito è un abito
un pochettino più particolare e cioè è
quello della salute
siamo al teatro colosseo 800 persone
proponiamo un video gioco che si chiama
keep talking e non va a disp l'on
l'obiettivo del gioco è semplicemente
quello di disinnescare un ordigno
abbiamo due persone che sono le vittime
che si dirigono sul palco fronte palco
col computer davanti il computer che la
bomba dietro le quinte sei persone
gli esperti col manuale che contiene
tutte le istruzioni per riuscire a
disinnescare i moduli della bomba
appunto si rifugia dietro le quinte
unica comunicazione possibile la
comunicazione audio che c'è tra il
gruppo delle vittime e il gruppo degli
esperti
il tutto in cinque minuti
chi tolkien nobody's plot è un
videogioco molto particolare è un
videogioco fiji tal cioè in parte fisico
perché io ho i manuali di carta e lì
dentro che c'è scritta la soluzione o le
soluzioni del gioco dall'altra digitale
perché la bomba è creata dentro il
computer
l'obiettivo del gioco non è solo
divertire
ma è fare in modo di capire come
collaborano e come comunicano due gruppi
di persone con la sola comunicazione
audio il fatto che noi li abbiamo
separati fisicamente e quella meccanica
di gioco che noi aggiungiamo per
riuscire a creare una maggiore
immersività e per fare in modo che il
gioco è questa parte formativa funzioni
meglio nell'ambito invece della salute
proviamo a immaginare un qualsiasi gioco
di racing
proviamo a pensare di usare questo gioco
di racing per riuscire a riabilitare
delle persone che hanno avuto un
incidente stradale
pensiamo di offrire al medico la
possibilità di personalizzare le
esperienze di guida di questo gioco di
racing in modo tale che si possa
effettuare una desensibilizzazione
sistematica del trauma nei confronti del
paziente il medico allora comincerà a
proporre un percorso un tracciato al
paziente in modo molto rilassato magari
fissando la velocità del veicolo a 30
chilometri all'ora
va bene ok aumentiamo la velocità
andiamo a 60 va ancora bene quella
facciamo un'altra aggiunta i veicoli
quindi cominciamo a capire che in strada
ci sono anche altre persone
in tutti e due questi ambiti di fatto
quello che capita e che non solo
l'immersione partecipa al fatto di
coinvolgere il paziente o di gruppo che
esco subisce la formazione ma c'è anche
quella caratteristica del videogioco che
si chiama il riscontro immediato il
feedback che fa capire subito
assolutamente che la cosa è andata bene
oppure che la cosa sia andata male non
lo capisco dopo mesi lo intercetto
subito e magari
il videogioco mi dice anche che in che
cosa posso migliorare la volta dopo
fatto così la vicenda funzionare
perfettamente
c'è un ma il mae che noi adulti non
siamo abituati a giocare quindi dobbiamo
trovare un qualcosa affinché questa
esperienza sia efficace dentro di noi
io stesso se associo un momento di gioco
mentre lavoro nonostante sia 12 anni che
lavori nella gameindustry costretto a
questo tarlo comincia accendere del
gioco oa fare i miei lavori e poi dietro
vedo sempre che c'è una una persona
magari il collega che temo che pensi che
io stia a casse giando che si stia
avviando perché beh comunque dai giochi
al lavoro quindi non la cosa non e
invece no se noi riusciamo a mettere
quello che si chiama il momento di
restituzione cioè un momento di
condivisione per quelli che hanno appena
in qualche modo vissuto l'esperienza di
gioco sia formativa sia diciamo relativa
alla salute ecco che grazie al formato
real medico il gioco può avere la
metafora svelata cioè il significato del
gioco riesce a trasferirsi meglio nella
vita delle persone proprio perché noi
non siamo abituati ad associare quello
che un'esperienza il gioco magari
nell'ambito lavorativo
ma non è solo questo il videogioco a 3
power up come si dice nel gergo tra i
potenziamenti incredibili che ne
potenziano ancora di più l'efficacia
il primo è che utilizzando la struttura
del videogioco assieme le grandi
capacità computazionali del computer
io posso offrire scenari molto complessi
in modo semplice la generazione invece
procedurale dei contenuti mi permette di
creare infiniti contenuti ma tenendo
sotto controllo quello che può essere la
difficoltà e la complessità del problema
che voglio proporre esiste anche un
monitoraggio oggettivo che viene dato
certamente da quelli che sono gli
oggetti
elementi di gioco propri dei videogiochi
i punti livelli ma io come programmatore
posso mettere un monitoraggio nascosto
che mi registra tutta la performance o
del gruppo di persone o del mio paziente
questo monitoraggio oggettivo quindi va
a unirsi a quel monitoraggio soggettivo
che solitamente offre il medico o il
gruppo cioè lo sguardo del formatore
sulla vicenda che sta capitando oppure
hai fatto di rivedere il video
una volta finita l'esperienza il
videogioco è uno strumento e dobbiamo
pensarla in questo modo se la
letteratura con lo scrittore racconta al
proprio pubblico con le parole la
vicenda il cinema fa in modo che il
registro ci offra il suo occhio con la
regia per raccontare la sua storia in
questo caso il pubblico è il
protagonista della storia
cosa possiamo allora sognare e cosa
vorrei segnare io per i prossimi anni
che gli studi di sviluppo di videogiochi
commerciali possano sviluppare quella
parte quel complemento che permetta di
usare i loro prodotti a fini formativi
per la salute o per qualsiasi altro fine
che la creatività ci potrà ispirare e
dall'altra parte il secondo sogno è
quello che il videogioco sia sdoganato
completamente dal solo obiettivo del
divertimento non possa essere
considerato uno strumento che racconta
delle cose che da dei messaggi
importanti
e allora se mio nonno fosse ancora in
vita
in questo momento oggi quali storie
incredibili avrebbe potuto raccontarmi
con questo nuovo e magico strumento
grazie
[Applauso]